it's been a bad 12 months for covet hit
retail and hospitality we've got a
complete grocery offer green grocery
through to bottle goods through to
delicate tests and bread from a
fantastic bakery down in foxton
but for small and medium-sized
businesses like this one importing stock
from the eu
what lies ahead is also uncertain thanks
to brexit we're talking about small
businesses who then have to digest
through
these great trade deals between between
states right i think
of course we're the economic end of it
so that clarity is coming around can my
business
actually survive through the realities
you know and then for us we're fortunate
we can look at other sourcing we can
look around and see well
we can no longer get a french free for
argument's sake because the price point
does that give an opportunity
to an english breed so there are
opportunities there from fresh produce
to fine wine importers and exporters
alike
the reality of britain's breakup with
its largest market
is becoming clear the light switched on
and
it dawned on us that actually
this wasn't going to be a quick fix this
wasn't going to go away
all of a sudden the cheshire cheese
company has shelved investment plans to
cope with previously growing
sales to eu consumers the search is on
for alternatives one door closes another
one opens
we already shipped to the usa and canada
we could
probably spend a heck of a lot less and
maybe fill that up by
chasing chasing business in other parts
of the world
and effectively leave the eu completely
and utterly out of the equation for the
time being
the main choke point for trade is here
dover
where preparations have been made for
new border checks and
not far away vast lorry parks have been
created in anticipation of long delays
a month since the uk eu trade deal was
struck and several weeks since it came
into effect and most of the cues and
congestion have been down to covert 19.
drivers having to be tested before they
make their way to france the
actual volumes of trade have been fairly
low businesses making use
of stockpiled supplies but as those
supplies begin to dwindle
the expectation is that perhaps within
days something like
normal volumes of trade will resume
likely causing further delays adding to
the difficulties faced by businesses and
entrepreneurs attempting to navigate
complex custom systems
fees and paperwork where once there was
mutually beneficial
frictionless trade across the channel in
some cases now
the breaks are being applied jonah hull
al jazeera dover